how do you overcome the suffering of
life is be a better person
that's how you do it well that's hard
it takes responsibility and I think you
know if you said to someone you want to
have a meaningful life
everything you do matters
that's the definition of a meaningful
life but everything you do matters
[Music]
Jordan Peterson has undoubtedly been one
of the most influential intellectuals of
the past decade his ability to Captivate
audiences with his eloquence and
intellect is unquestionable but how does
a man go from this your responsibility
is to Incarnate the spirit of the logos
that's your responsibility that's your
role in life
and
that is independent to some degree in
whether or not you accept the idea of a
Transcendent and eternal reality
now I'm not
making a case for that or against that I
those things are Beyond human
understanding but
we know what happens if people act
poorly
if men act badly we know what happens we
know that the world turns into something
that's so close to hell that the
difference is Trivial we know that
that's the story of the 20th century
so we should learn that lesson
and what that lesson is is
pick up the world on your shoulders and
walk forward pick up the world with all
of its trouble with all of its suffering
with all of its evil
and move forward with it and in bearing
that burden learn that your
the sort of creature that can bear that
burden and therefore deserving of
respect
to this
I like the unabashedly Shameless
capitalist ethos of the daily wire crew
they made me a great deal financially
one that offers me essentially unlimited
creative freedom and opportunity and
still means that I can use YouTube as I
have been to offer free content to a
worldwide audience I've always deemed
myself an evil capitalist I run my own
businesses on a for-profit basis with
few exceptions learning through hard
experience that the discipline imposed
by the necessity of pleasing an audience
on an ongoing basis is a plus not a
minus
in order to make sense of this we need
to go back and analyze Peterson's
progress with a critical eye Peterson
entered the vernacular in 2018 when he
became viral after having an argument
with a trans activist in the campus of
University of Toronto I want to go talk
to Peterson
the protest
the presence of Nazis and white
supremacists assaulting people at your
protest do you have any comment on that
yeah
then why why were they here
are there are there views in alignment
with yours at some point
look if you want to know what my views
are I've watched all of your videos yes
including yes yes I have yes then why
would you ask such a question because
this is my interpretation in your video
apparently all of the people who arrange
the protest against you watched all of
your videos do you want to disavow 150
videos on YouTube no your lectures which
sparked the debate okay
would you let me talk to her for a
moment don't call me that please
so I have 150 lectures on YouTube
there's 500 hours of My Views do you
really think that you're worth all of
that time
I will answer your question okay I've
studied Nazism for a very long time it's
been four decades and I understand it
very well and I can tell you that
there's some awful people lurking in the
corners and they're ready to come out
and if the radical left keeps pushing
away that's very much that sounds very
much like a threat yeah it sounds very
much like a threat would you like to
disavow the physical violence trans
people were physically assaulted at this
rally in your name would you like to
disavow that violence so you wish that
didn't happen and you want to and I'm
going to post this online that you would
like people to not to be to be more
accommodating of trans people and people
of color at your events in future
I'm a person of color and I felt very
accommodated
if you like this guy in the past the
discussion was quite heated and Peterson
managed to draw a lot of attention
because of his composure and Clarity
after that incident he got constantly
invited to interviews and many
considered him as the most important
intellectual of our time but throughout
the years he has undergone a significant
transformation and I wanted to delve
into this transformation in order to
understand what is happening we need to
go way back before Peterson was a
popular figure
now if you have any belief system at all
you do this so let's say you're an
advocate of left-wing politics you take
a pro-environmental stance or an
anti-corporate stance this is a
relatively common thing to do among
undergraduates
what do you do when you hold that belief
system
you view the world as it lays itself out
and you explain the manner in which it
manifests itself in terms of the axioms
of that belief system and you may know
that you can do it right you can tell a
credible story about why the world is
the Way It Is by adopting say an
anti-corporate perspective because there
are all sorts of terrible things about
the world that are a consequence say of
corporate maneuvering situation and
Peter pan pan means everything a pan
like pantheistic and Japan is a child
who won't grow up now he's magical well
well children live in a magical world
right they're Rife with possibility he's
magical he doesn't want to grow up
so he lives in Neverland with the Lost
Boys Neverland doesn't really exist and
the lost boys are obviously boys who
haven't managed to establish some mode
of being and he's in constant battle
with Captain Hook and Captain Hook's a
tyrant right a pirate a negative
a manifestation of the negative
archetype of social order and Captain
Hook is always fighting Peter Pan
because Peter Pan represents childhood
and vulnerability and he doesn't want to
be vulnerable so they're locked in this
sort of eternal battle and lots of
people I think more commonly men but not
necessarily
get caught in this Peter Pan problem we
can clearly see that Peterson even as a
young academic had fire in his heart he
was very articulate and he was
constantly trying to discover ways to
deeply analyze The Human Condition in
his first book maps of meaning he
attempts to formulate a theory for how
people construct meaning in a way that
is compatible with a modern scientific
understanding of how the brain functions
I read the book and it was quite the
read this is how Peterson won me over I
was desperately looking for modern
intellectuals to look up to and he
ticked all the boxes some of his
interviews from 2018 are mesmerizing to
say their least
I don't know what
happens to a person if they bring
themselves completely into alignment
I've had intimations of what that might
mean
we don't understand the world very well
we don't understand how the world could
be mastered if it was mastered
completely we don't know how an
individual might be able to manage that
we don't know what Transformations that
might make possible
people think especially when they're
nihilistic and they and they become
destructive that the universe is sort of
it's an unfair and arbitrary place and
it's basically bent on their random
destruction well they suffer it's
something like that yeah right okay what
do you do under those circumstances
that's the question well
one potential answer is
twist the things so that you can maybe
get what you hypothetically want out of
it
the other is
rely on your perceptions and your
capacity for accurate representation
communicate that and take your chances
it's like who's right well that's the
battle between good and evil who's right
it's a continual battle
because I'd also say that if you haven't
done that kind of Shadow work if you
haven't made friends with your anger if
you haven't integrated it you're
actually more dangerous yes because then
things will happen that will it will
come out in a way that you don't expect
right it comes out disintegrated so it
comes out as an autonomous Spirit right
under no one's control and that's like a
burst of Rage let's say you either have
that or it has you those are the options
and you don't become safe by being
castrated right that's not the right
move forward
you can actually see
a change in people's faces when that
part of them is integrated when the I
would say the rage circuit is integrated
because their faces hardened like they
no longer look like wide-eyed children
that they're no longer someone to whom
things only happen there there's someone
who makes things happen and there isn't
much difference between being dangerous
and being indomitable right they're this
they're the they're they're the same
thing looked at from two different
perspectives
it also became apparent to me that he
was a deeply religious person and as an
agnostic myself I wanted to understand
why he was so adamant about religion if
you if you don't want to move into a
metaphysical space I'm not arguing for
the existence of God I'm arguing that
the ethic that drives our culture is
predicated on the idea of God and that
you can't just take that idea away and
expect the thing to remain intact
mid-air without any foundational support
religion for him leads to the
development of the self we live in an
age where people struggle to find
meaning and the idea of self-development
appeals to most of us there's this idea
in jungian Psychology called the
circumambulation and Jung had this idea
that you had a potential future self
which would be in potential everything
that you could be and that it manifests
itself moment to moment in your present
Life by making you interested in things
and the things that you're interested in
are the things that would guide you
along the path that would lead you to
maximal development now it sounds like a
metaphysical idea or a or a mystical
idea even but but it's not it's it's not
it's a really profoundly biological idea
the idea is something like well
you're set up so that you're
automatically interested in those things
that would fully expand you as a
well-adapted creature and that's how the
famous clean up your room idea came into
prominence
clean up your room
that's a good start organize your local
landscape schedule your time start
taking control of yourself see if you
can stop saying things you know to be
live Peterson was also quite fond of
myths and religions he wanted to
understand the essence of the stories
we've been told and how they shape our
societies so Isis Queen of the
underworld gives birth to Horus and
Horus grows up outside the kingdom why
in Underworld because that's what human
beings do you're alienated from your
culture always why it's old and dead and
corrupt and so that leaves you growing
up in chaos uh what would you call
alienated from your fundamental culture
that's the story of adolescence
Horus grows up he can see that's what
differentiates him from Osiris that's
why he's a falcon he goes and has a
fight with Seth and now the difference
between Osiris and and Horus is that
Horus does not underestimate Seth he
knows exactly what he's up against he
goes and has a terrible battle with him
trying to get his kingdom back something
else that's echoed in the Lion King's
Story and well Horus and and Osiris or
Seth are fighting Seth tears out one of
his eyes
now why
because Seth is the embodiment of
Destruction and malevolence and no
matter how conscious you are if you
encounter that even voluntarily the
probability that it's going to damage
your Consciousness is extraordinarily
High that's why people don't do it
so the eyes torn out but Seth is
defeated and Horus
banishes him to the nether regions of
the Kingdom you can't kill him why
because the malevolent destructive force
the threatened States Never Dies it's
always there you can only remove it
temporarily now Horus is King
Pharaoh King God he's got his eye and so
you think well he's going to just pop
that back in his hand and then he's
going to be able to lead
he's going to be able to take his place
at the uppermost Pantheon Pantheon of
gods properly
but that isn't what he does
he takes his eye and he goes back to the
underworld just like Pinocchio going
into the depths to rescue Geppetto and
down there is the spirit of Osiris who's
who's extant as a kind of half-dad ghost
and he gives Osiris his eye
now Osiris can see
so what does that mean
you go down into the chaotic wind
threatened by malevolence even to the
point of
damage to your Consciousness you go down
into the chaos and you find the dead
Spirit of your tradition and you give it
vision
and so provided with vision Osiris
regenerates and then Osiris and Horus go
back up to to to the world
linked together and Rule jointly
and the Egyptians believed
that the pharaoh who had an immortal
Spirit was the embodiment of the
conjunction of Horus and Osiris and
that's what gave him sovereignty and so
you think about how brilliant that is
the Egyptians are trying to puzzle out
who should lead
who should be pharaoh and what do you
have to be if you're going to be Pharaoh
in order for things to work
you have to be awake to malevolence and
chaos and you have to embody your
tradition
I mean you know in the story the Tower
of Babel human beings make this massive
building that's supposed to reach up to
the heavens so that it'll take the place
of God well that's that's the earliest
warning we have of the danger of making
things so big that you confuse them with
God and God gets irritated and comes
down and makes everybody speak different
languages and scatters them it's like
well that's what happens when you try to
make something a totality is that it
starts to fragment inside and and
disintegrates into catastrophe and so
it's it's almost as we have to maintain
this articulated space inside the dream
inside the custom something like that
because otherwise it doesn't work and I
think that's the same as having respect
for the fact that we have bodies you
know we're not just abstract creatures
that follow rules we're not that at all
we only follow certain rules
we won't follow the other ones and our
societies will crumble and so and we
just don't know enough to articulate the
entire landscape of behavior with
articulated rules not at all we can't do
it it's beyond us
eventually he became very famous and
started giving speeches all over the
world and amassed a huge and hardcore
following the mainstream media wanted to
Target him for his controversial views
but this didn't always end up well why
should your right to freedom of speech
Trump a trans persons right not to be
offended
because in order to be able to think you
have to risk being offensive I mean look
at the conversation we're having right
now
you know like you're certainly willing
to risk offending me in the pursuit of
Truth why should you have the right to
do that it's been rather uncomfortable
well I'm I'm very glad I put you on this
call well
you get my point it's like you're you're
doing what you should do which is
digging a bit to see what the hell's
going on and that is what you should do
but you're exercising your freedom of
speech to certainly risk offending me
and that's fine I think more power to
you as far as I'm concerned so you
haven't sat there and
I'm just right I've just tried to work
that out I mean
huh gotcha you have got me you have got
me I'm trying to work that through my
head yeah yeah it took a while it took a
while yeah it did yeah
other great intellectuals showed
interest in him and he had some very
intense debates with people like Sam
Harris and slavojijic you that
I'm not characterizing here enemy or
what you are fighting against ever
sometimes you call it a postmodern
neo-marxism I know what you mean all
this from political correctness to these
excesses of whatever uh spirit of envy
and so on and so on
I don't know them I would ask you here
give me some names or whatever where are
the marxists here I don't know any I
don't who who is the Marxist here so
show me any big names of political
correctness I think they they fear like
a good vampire fears garlic any this is
why they are already the one who is not
America's but at least approach this
economic topic Bernie Sanders he is
already under attack as white male and
all that stuff and so on I simply I
simply
my problem would be this one what you
describe as
postmodern neo-marxism where is really
the Marxist element in it therefore
equality sorry well therefore equality
at this cultural struggles or proper
names how do we call each other do you
see in them in political correctness and
thrown any genuine will off to change
society I don't see I think it's a hyper
moralization hyper moralization which is
a silent admission of a defeat
that's my problem why do you call give
me no it again it's not a rhetorical
question for politely saying you are an
idiot you don't know what you're talking
about it's simply I would like to know
because you and I like this often when
you attack somebody you said
aggressively and what truth read more
tell me whom so I'm asking you now not
read more I don't advise you but who are
give me some names and so on and who are
these postmodern egalitarian neo-marxist
and where do you see any kind even of
Marxism I see in it mostly and an
important and utterly impotent
moralization
to take Christianity as an example
what do you believe about this the
origin of this sacred book The Bible all
the New Testament do you believe that
just maybe it has a status
unlike any other book or is it
simply old writing of human beings just
like ourselves I think it's both okay so
but but but so what does that mean
you're saying you're saying that there's
somebody who's taking dictation that is
unlike any other dictation so so Homer
though creative or Shakespeare though
creative sources of inspiration okay
everyone's been inspired if you talk to
creative people yes you know they
basically they often describe themselves
as something approximating a conduit
through which higher wisdom is pouring
again you're dodging shakes that
Shakespeare could say that and yeah and
any writer can say that right ultimately
right and it's also the case that that
we would or we would rank organize we
would rank order those writers which is
why you pointed to Shakespeare in terms
of the generalizable validity of their
Revelations sure and so well look so so
you run into the same issue you know you
criticized the Bible and to look fair
enough you know but you're you're also
evading a very important issue which is
how do you how do you quantitatively
rank the contributions of literature
without assuming that there's a
hierarchy of Revelation although there's
a hierarchy of wisdom sure there's a
hierarchy of human wisdom I will grant
you that every day of the week but this
it is but we're talking about primates
like ourselves having conversations and
this is the most important game we can
play and this this is the best game in
town and it has always been so but
people are imagining and it includes as
you said at the outset what I would call
spiritual experience and spiritual
experience is admits of a fact-based
discussion about the nature of human
consciousness and why do you allow that
as an exception like because it's not an
exception it's part of the the data set
so it's possible to have spiritual so
this is spiritual experience without the
possible of possibility of concretized
Revelation so it's a formless
spirituality that you're advocating no
no it it you you can have I'm not even
I'm not even discounting the possibility
that there are invisible entities out
there in the universe far smarter than
ourselves who we could possibly be in
dialogue with I mean there are many
strange ideas that we we could defend to
one another degree but you there are
people walking around speculating that
we might be living in a computer
simulation that all of this is being run
on some hard drive of the future or or
some you know alien supercomputer now
that you can actually I mean Nick
Bostrom at Oxford gives a very cogent
argument in defense of that thesis right
now you can you can deal with that on
its marriage I'm not saying the universe
isn't Stranger than we suppose or even
can suppose but
one thing we know is that when you read
the Bible you can turn every page of
that book
and you will not find evidence of
omniscience you will not find anything
in there that someone as smart as
Shakespeare or actually a little bit
Dumber could have written
everyone thought that he was invincible
and that there was no end to his Ascent
but then he collapsed Peterson got
addicted to benzos and this had a
detrimental effect on his health it
appeared in some sense that the reason I
was Ill was because I was taking
benzodiazepames but that isn't why I was
ill and then I took them and very low
dose and I took that for a long time and
it helped whatever was wrong with me and
it looks like it was an allergy or maybe
multiple allergies
and then
that stopped working and so I took a
little bit more for about a month and
that made it way worse and so then I cut
back a lot and then then things really
got out of hand and so he had to
disappear from the spotlight for some
time and get hospitalized in a facility
in Serbia in order to overcome his
addiction
hi everyone
as some of you may know but others will
not
it's been a long while since I put up
any new content on this YouTube channel
I've been suffering from
impaired Health severely impaired health
as a consequence of
benzodiazepine use for anxiety or more
accurately from a combination of using
that medication and then ceasing its use
once I realized it was dangerous
um
that's put me in and out of hospitals
for much of the last year
in
Connecticut in the United States in
Toronto in Canada in Moscow
in Russia and in Belgrade Serbia
as
my family searched for Specialists who
could Aid me in the severe post-use
withdrawal and
neurological damage related consequences
of
both the benzodiazepine use and and its
cessation
however he managed to recover from it
and he did an impressive comeback a few
years ago but there was something we
couldn't really see behind the curtain
one person saw it though and he opened
my eyes to something very important
Peterson was very bright
extraordinary articulates
and in some ways a compelling speaker so
he's an attractive figure in some ways
when I read him I sense a lot of
suppressed rage in him
in fact I think his voice is choking
with her age a lot of the time it's
interesting because he talks about rage
that you have to deal with it I don't
think you'd understand just how angry he
is and this and and if you look at his
websites the comments
are full of Rage
by his young acolytes
now that's an energetic thing
but that it's his energy that draws
people as much as
what he actually teaches
Dr Peterson despite being a highly
intellectual person couldn't control his
rage he's a psychologist a person with a
lot of patience and empathy but the
toxicity of the people that were against
him especially from the left got under
his skin he got bitter and was
overwhelmed with rage and that was
something that conservatives try to
capitalize on at some point Peterson
decided to join daily wire plus a medium
owned by conservative Ben Shapiro
the plan is to build a multimedia Empire
offering services on the philosophical
educational journalistic and
entertainment front including movies TV
shows and media for children and an
Empire that will not fall prey to the
woke authoritarianism that has become
increasingly mandatory in so many places
as he says what he's fighting against
this decision feels strange to me but
there are two ways to interpret it
either that he was deeply hurt by the
toxicity of the left and had to choose
sides or that he was always a hardcore
conservative and he was just hiding
behind the facade of intellectualism I
personally don't have a problem with
someone identifying as a conservative
but if you decide to do so be a
conscious conservative I think when Dr
Peterson decided to pick sides he did so
because he became resentful and that's
the case with a lot of intellectuals
nowadays when they say something that
the left does not agree with they get
criticized harshly and sometimes they
even get canceled I understand where
this aggressive rhetoric comes from but
it really alienates some great
intellectuals Jordan Peterson was a
great asset and had to be treated as
such when he decides to pick a side he
will eventually need to follow the
agenda of that side that's not how we
progress as a society intellectuals are
assets that allow us to follow reason
and fight propaganda they are archetypes
that allow us to navigate through the
unknown by showing us a way and helping
us recalibrate our moral compass if this
accomp to special interests for whatever
reason this hinders progress and
perpetuates the current problems that we
all face as I said maybe he was always
like that but maybe he wasn't the jury
is still out there
[Music]
uh
foreign foreign foreign